was there a part in your career where
your ego started to get big like you
felt that going on in your world like
i've noticed that in my own life at
times your ego because it's kind of like
this plant that gets watered by not even
you water in it you know it's this thing
that grows sometimes did you ever have
any uh i would say
more in the in the like mid to late 80s
when all of a sudden we were thrust into
stardom
and in a thing that we never imagined
we'd be famous at because no one was
famous at it and then all of a sudden
we're traveling the world and there's
crowds and then that that definitely
gets to you at when you're in such an
impressionable impressionable formative
age so when i'm like 18 19 traveling the
world thousands of people autographs
you know parties girls everything and it
was just like at some point i think that
i took it for granted yeah and maybe
even expected it
and then it was all taken away from me
because skating died and now
now that i get to live through another
wave of success i don't take any of it
for granted and i'm right just so
thankful that i even get paid to do it
at all
um i'm glad i went through that
yeah dude when like
like with the ego do you think it like
um it's you think it's just something
that happens to people because that's an
interesting experience that you've had
where you got to like
you know you just got to have
you know popularity and stuff like that
i feel like the people who have the
worst egos are the ones that
get into it for those motivations
they get into it for fame or fortune
and then when they finally get it they
just expect it
and
maybe that'll last for a little bit but
at some point people are over you yeah
if you're walking around like you
deserve all of it they had a plan it was
a secret plan to be an [ __ ] the whole
time oh
yeah that's what it looks like yeah
because some people are just like i knew
you before you were that right and now
we're still on the same [ __ ] planet
dude with the same skin on and you're
acting like all of a sudden you're made
of [ __ ] diamonds but you do see those
same those same people
lose their motivation and they don't
keep their skills up because it was
never there probably to begin with or it
was it was there but but they the
motivation was just to get to this point
right of celebrity and when they get to
that point they don't they're not
motivated to get better and that's when
they fall off
and so in my case i just want to keep
getting better at skating
thank god that was there for you then
just because it's like that kind of
stuff can happen you know it's like
sometimes i think it happens and people
don't realize it till years later you
know like what was even going on if you
realized that at the time you probably
stopped
like what do you mean like if you're
being an egotistical [ __ ] right
you're not appreciating where you are
and you realize that right there and
then then you would hopefully he would
stop or
make a like get on the right track or
try to get on the right track i've done
it i did it with the radio skateboarding
i was famous not as famous as him but
famous enough to be an [ __ ] and fly
around the world and be like ah
it was nothing i wasn't like on purpose
mean but i was definitely
like not appreciative of
the people and all the
the life that i was living just like no
thank you just [ __ ] give me the [ __ ]
give me the money give me juice
[Laughter]
and then the radio same thing yeah got i
didn't it was accidental got real big
all of a sudden people are all up my ass
and then i'm straight back into that
thing running everybody i know what i'm
doing [ __ ] nobody knows anything
and then had to you know go that's when
i started going to therapy and [ __ ]
because i couldn't have a relationship
yeah like i could be the boss of a show
but nobody would date me oh dude that's
where i'm at
really yeah nobody will date you because
what do you snap on people or something
no people can date me i just have
trouble like with commitment and stuff
like that like i've just been and i've
just been i've just had so much anger
and i don't know what i'm angry at
that that is i know exactly what that is
being super angry and not knowing why
that was the thing that made me go
because i was
i had everything i was like i have
everything that i'd ever want like
you're on fire and all you do is [ __ ]
talk about dicks
and then you go home and do whatever you
want like this is
no and what was your other job i was a
skateboarder yeah like come on you can't
get a better life and you're just no or
you know i mean i really just want to
listen to some dark metal by myself and
think about pulling things apart like
what's wrong with you dude
oh i'll go get those chickens at the
store and just take them apart man
wait are they cooked huh
oh yeah they're cooked they're
pre-cooked yeah do you eat it when you
pull it up [ __ ] it what do you just
leave it creep bro but i'll put it on
what do you mean you buy a chicken to
pull it apart i'll put on elliot smith
or some sad music and just [ __ ] carve
that [ __ ] up so do you eat it as well
or you're just carving i'll have a
little sometimes but sometimes it's more
for the sport of it honestly you know
it's like yeah somebody just got to let
it's just like i just want yeah i don't
know i just get i've just been angry and
man it's been it has been not fun you
know
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two
options watch one this one or this one